T'challah here showed me there was more than
one way to reallocate the universe's resources
sometimes the best weapon in your arsenal is
just a good argument aye aye commander
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my full marvel
what if episode 2 video what if t'challa became
star lord what if black panther became star lord
so we'll break it all down there's a ton of easter
eggs so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes i'll be doing
videos for everything this season we're also doing
a giveaway for disney plus memberships all you do
to enter is be a subscriber and just let me know
what your favorite moment from the episode was
your favorite easter egg it'll probably wind up
being one of the best episodes from the season
like it was an amazing episode i'll just number
these as we go along through moments and easter
eggs but starting with the episode title what if
t'challa became star lord the title says it all
in the big deal as the chadwick boseman came back
to do the voice of his character he was fantastic
in the episode they said that he was super excited
for the project like a lot of big actors wouldn't
necessarily want to do television but they said
that chadwick boseman was really hyped up about
playing this version of star lord during the
series he's in a total of four episodes this
season so he'll be in three more episodes after
this and they had a special dedication to him
in the end credits as well so while this episode
was mostly a blending of the black panther movie
in the guardians of the galaxy movies you could
also kind of think of it as a fast and furious
style episode because they get into his family
in wakanda king t'chaka shuri his mother the
ravagers yondu his surrogate father his surrogate
family even thanos's family they even addressed
that storyline through the guardians films with
his relationship with nebula don't worry also
addressed what's going on with gamora during the
what if series because she didn't appear in this
episode but she is also still a daughter of thanos
during this and if we're making fast and furious
family references you also have the vin diesel
connection because he is the voice of groot
even though there was no groot during this
obviously there were a couple big characters
that were missing and not every single movie actor
came back to do the voice of their characters but
here's a quick preview of that these are all the
actors that actually came back the actual episode
begins with that same twilight zone style intro as
episode 1 which jeffrey writes watcher narrating
time space reality is more than a linear path it's
a prism of endless possibility talking about how
a single choice can itself lead to a nexus event
branching out into many subsequent realities so
this is like the loki explainer again the watchers
describing how nexus events work and how in the
loki finale scene where you see major branch
timelines growing off the sacred timeline then on
each of those major branches many smaller branch
timelines split off even more and so on and so
forth until you get to the current real version of
the multiverse the true version of the multiverse
this opening scene 2 is the same beginning
of the guardians of the galaxy movie on morag
with the same scene of what used to be peter quill
coming to take the power stone except this time
it's t'challa star lord and his costume is mostly
the same but it's like a black panther inspired
version of peter quill's costume almost everything
about this scene goes down the same it happens the
same way just a little bit faster because it's
a 20 plus minute episode they have to condense
a two-hour plus movie down into almost 30 minutes
so everything just happens way faster jaime hansu
came back to do the voice of korath just like
chadwick boseman came back and the other main
guardians characters for the most part and the
first big twist happens when they do that same
scene of you might know me by another name
star lord and this time instead of the who
it turns out this alternate korath is a huge
fanboy of t'challa's then when he's yelling at
his men to stand down they use that voiceover to
explain how this version of t'challa's star lord
is viewed by the rest of this version of the
universe since he's grown up he's become this
cosmic robin hood version of the character
and outlaw stealing from the rich giving to
the poor so almost everybody everywhere around the
universe loves him one of the funnier things about
the episode is that he winds up being a way better
version of star lord than chris pratt's version of
star lord but that's the way he's written he's
kind of written to be a dirtbag that eventually
becomes good so that's meant to be his arc during
the live-action marvel movies they're having a
little bit more fun with t'challa's version of
star lord the whole joke about him not being sure
if he should bow should i kneel maybe i should
kneel it's just a call back to avengers infinity
war where roadie tricked the hulk into bowing
to him and he said no no we don't do that here
this korath is still working for ronan he's still
here to take the power stone for him but he hates
to do it because he loves t'challa star lord so
much he even offers to defect and switch sides
to become a ravager just so that he could get to
work with his hero they have that big funny fight
scene that they turn into a joke oh it's such an
honor should i use the gun should i not use the
gun t'challa winds up coaching him through their
fight jokingly luring him into taking himself
out by making contact with the force field then
sort of reinforcing the idea that he's this very
benevolent person and he always tries to help
people he says oh well i've hired worse people so
i guess you can join the crew too and just throws
him over his shoulder like okay i guess we're
taking another person onto the team this is also
meant to be set up for how he was able to talk
thanos down don't worry we'll get to the thanos
of it all in a second too because he became this
big thing through the episode it was really fun to
hear josh brolin play the good version of thanos
captain genocide reporting for duty they have
that funny scene from the trailer where he tries
to set up yondu's grand entrance with the fin
and the arrow weapon from the comics and it's
michael rooker coming back to do the voice of
his character from the movies a ravager never
flies solo which they also pay off at the end
of the episode as well when they're fighting the
collector so in this universe they explain instead
of selling the power stone to someone like the
collector t'challa's plan is to use its power to
jumpstart the crylorians dying star and save their
entire system from extinction just paying off that
setup earlier saying that he's a cosmic robin hood
going around helping people the crylorians are
actually another reference to the guardians of the
galaxy movies they're the pink skinned people that
karina's people belong to the collector's servants
like the same pink skinned alien that peter quill
was boning on the milano then they flashed back to
1988 wakanda and the watcher explains how t'challa
became star lord so 1988 it's the same year yondu
picked up peter quill as a boy in missouri so in
this reality t'challa is bored of life in wakanda
calling it a bubble quote unquote because it's a
reference to the shield over wakanda metaphorical
and literal bubble protecting it from the world
he's wearing the same outfit that the live-action
young t'challa wore in the black panther movie
his father king tachaka who still black panther
at this time because he's still pretty young is
wearing the exact same black panther suit that he
wore in the flashbacks in the black panther movie
and if you couldn't tell it's actually john connie
the actor who played older king tachaka from the
movies doing the voice of the character himself in
the movie though young to chaka was played by john
connie's real life son which is just a cool easter
egg he gets really meta here and as he walks
through the shield of wakanda yondu's ship shows
up and the ravagers carry him on board mistakenly
thinking that he is ego the living planet's son
it's sean gunn coming back to do cragolan and
chris sullivan doing taserface he was taserfaced
during the movies in this reality they explained
the reason for the mix-up is that yondu asked
them to find ego the living planet's child and
they were searching for extraterrestrial energy
signatures and wakanda just set off their sensors
because of the vibranium t'challa then explains
that to them oh my home is built on a vibranium
meteorite that's probably what you were detecting
they had been looking for extraterrestrial energy
signatures because of peter quill's celestial dna
which is also set up for the ending scene where
ego the living planet shows up to pick up peter
quill r.i.p this version of planet earth yondu
offers young t'challa a chance to join them like
why not come out and see the stars which he takes
them up on like hell yes so time jumped back to
present day 20 years later they're back during
the events of the first guardians of the galaxy
movie and they're all having drinks toasting the
ravagers you see korath enjoying himself newly
officially minted member he starts asking t'challa
about his favorite heist so they can kind of
explain his backstory a little bit clarifying that
each of the quote-unquote heists were actually
times that he stole from rich people to help save
planets when they referenced the heist on tarnac's
iv that's actually a reference to the capital of
the skrull empire so he's basically saying that
t'challa and the ravagers stole from the central
bank of the scroll empire and kara is a planet
of insect creatures called the sliggs from the
fantastic four comics then they said at the whole
thanos of it all asking him to explain how did you
get thanos to stop decimating half of the universe
and josh brolin himself comes back as thanos to
pat him on the shoulder and say that t'challa
literally just talked him out of it in a casual
conversation no joke that's how badass this
version of t'challa star lord is supposed to
be but the whole what if thanos here is what
if thanos became good so he's a ravager and they
spend the entire episode joking about his terrible
plan to commit genocide there's several points
in the episode where he tries to talk him down
to well you know there are some merits to it
it's very efficient but they just keep joking
like no that's genocide you're talking about you
are captain genocide now thanos clarifies that
t'challa showed him a better way to reallocate the
universe's resources so there would be enough for
everyone later in the episode they also introduced
the concept of the embers of genesis which will
also help balance quote unquote the universe so
in this reality there is no thanos collecting the
infinity stones although in a couple scenes when
nebula shows up they do make a reference to that
i think part of the reason for this is setting the
stage for final boss form ultron to become sort
of like the big boss level villain of this what if
version of avengers infinity war thanos also makes
this reference later in the episode where he says
power abhors a vacuum and because he's not seeking
that power of the infinity stones power up pours
a vacuum someone else winds up assembling all six
infinity stones and it just happens to be ultron
they reveal drax in this universe is a bartender
and the only reason why it's not dave bautista
doing the voice is because of apparently some
mix-up with his agents not telling him that they
offered him the part but he explains the reason
why he's a bartender here and just a huge fanboy
of t'challa is because he stopped ronan's cree
invasion on his homeworld that in the movies the
guardians of the galaxy movies killed his wife
and child so in this reality his family's still
alive and he never vowed revenge then we meet this
universe's version of nebula who's being called
heist nebula she's being played by karen gillan
who came back to do the voice she's got a blonde
wig and this is still thanos's daughter like i
said she's not part of the ravagers though they
explained that she still kind of hates thanos for
being a bad dad like she says that everything in
the past still happened they can't change the past
even though thanos in the present day has turned
good the reason why i don't think gamora appears
in this episode because she's also a daughter
of thanos is because they want to set up the
other alternate what-if version of gamora wearing
thanos's armor from avengers infinity war wielding
his double-bladed sword so we'll meet her
eventually too when he says that thanos has
taken up gardening that's a reference to avengers
infinity war and avengers end game with his garden
planet that he went to after snapping half the
universe then t'challa sets up the whole wakanda
arc during the episode especially the ending when
he says that in this universe he at least believed
falsely we learned that his wakanda was destroyed
at some point during his childhood when yondu
tried to return him later we learned yondu lied
to him so that he wouldn't go home he would stay
and explore stay part of their ravager family then
nebula sells him on the idea of stealing from the
collector and there's a couple twists within
twist they pull a very ocean's 11 style plot
where one of them explains the plan while the
plan is unfolding in real time and then you find
out about a couple of double and triple crosses
along the way but the big macguffin they say
they're stealing from the collector is the embers
of genesis cosmic dust from an ancient supernova
that can be used to terraform entire systems
just growing crops on a galactic scale feeding
millions and millions of planets so like i said
sort of paying off thanos plant like now we'll
have enough resources for the universe that
we won't need to go around killing anyone
you also notice when she's showing him this 3d
powerpoint presentation when the planet is being
terraformed it looks exactly like the presentation
the ego the living planet is giving to peter quill
during guardians 2 which i also think is meant to
be foreshadowing for the end of the episode when
he shows up at the dairy queen to collect him so
they continue the plot of the first guardians film
with them going to nowhere in the collector's base
only this time instead of going to sell him the
power stone they're going to steal the embers
of genesis but they're using the power stone
to steal the embers thanos also explains that when
he turned good the collector seized all of his
territory in his criminal empire so this version
of the collector is way more powerful politically
and physically because he's super jacked up with
that harness and he's got all the easter egg
weapons that he uses later in the episode don't
worry i'll talk about all those easter egg weapons
because it implies that a couple really big marvel
characters in avengers characters are dead in this
universe craiglin also has a joke referencing
that he almost went to work for the collector but
apparently turned him down because he didn't offer
health benefits like the ravagers do yondu makes
a literal robin hood reference explained that
t'challa told him the story of this folk hero from
earth also making a robin leech reference who's
the host of lifestyles in the rich and famous
they set up the idea of nowhere the head of a dead
celestial hopefully in the eternals movie we'll
get an easter egg paying this off too because
in the comics there is kind of an explainer for
which dead celestial this head belongs to most
people think that it's jamaiah the analyzer but
then thanos also explains that the black order is
working security for the collector since they're
no longer working for him they introduced them
ebony ma proxima midnight co-obsidian corvus glaib
and most of the black order actors from the
movies from avengers infinity war came back to
do their voices except for a corvus glaibe it was
carrie coon doing proxima midnight and tom lawler
as ebony maw they do their ocean's eleven style
montage explaining the heist while intercutting
with the heist actually unfolding nebula enters
the front door she's greeted by karina from the
original guardians movie and it's the same actress
from the movie ophelia lovabond doing the voice of
the character they pull a trojan horse putting
t'challa inside the box that's supposed to house
the power stone lying to the collector saying
that they're bringing him the infinity stone
which is all plot from the first guardians of
the galaxy movie they let thanos get revenge on
korath causing their distraction for calling him
captain genocide and then his t'challa takes off
in search for the embers in the collector's
vast vaulted treasures they pay off a whole
bunch of easter eggs so a lot of these are just
silhouettes so you can't quite see who these are
meant to be but they're just meant to show you
that the collector has a bunch of people that
he also collects which they pay off at the end of
the episode when karina releases them and they all
wind up teaming up to kill him karma coming back
around with him making a literal karma reference
when the collector says that he's old enough to
remember when the ravagers used to be fun that's
also meant to be a reference to him being an elder
of the universe in the comics one of the oldest
living beings next to the celestials they bring
back cosmo just like in the original movie who
t'challa takes pity on freeing him later they call
him a stowaway but i think that t'challa let him
on the wakandan ship in the original guardians of
the galaxy movie james gunn said that he almost
put cosmo on the guardians team but decided not
to when he picked rocket and groot saying that
he felt like adding a talking dog on top of the
talking raccoon to the talking tree was just too
much too many talking animals apparently the blue
person here is just meant to be the same dark elf
from the original guardians of the galaxy movie
their couple dark elves inside the collector's
collection that you see later in the episode they
also bring back howard the duck for a big scene
and it is seth green coming back to do the voice
again from the movies he makes another dick joke
saying the collector's compensating for something
and then when he says he knows the collection and
starts telling him where to go to find the embers
he references that the collector has frost giants
in the collection cronins cronins are the race
of beings the korg belongs to the rock creatures
ryan reynolds also just did the korg deadpool
crossover which is i guess kind of canon to the
mcu the cronin shoutout is also meant to be
foreshadowing for the collector's weapon the
severed arm of the cronin that he's turned into a
weapon who they kind of imply is korg so r.i.p to
korg howard the duck makes another duck reference
like he did in the movies when you're out of luck
you always go duck the guardians 2 version of
this was once you go duck you never go back after
proxima midnight sounds the alarm they lock the
building down it sort of sets up t'challa finding
out about the wakandan spaceship when he ducks
into that hangar bay you see a whole bunch of
easter eggs in these ships the ship that's shaped
like a star is from the nova corps that they flew
in the first guardians movie the one below that is
from thor ragnarok there's the pod from avengers
infinity war that rocket and thor flew to the
dwarven home world to get stormbreaker then as he
runs past the wakandan ship his vibranium necklace
reacts to it activating the ship's systems and
they play the theme music from the black panther
movie king t'chaka and wakanda are very much alive
and thriving he created spaceships and sent the
dora melange out into space to search for him
this is meant to be a parallel for the message
that drax sent during the guardians of the galaxy
movie while the other guardians were with the
collector when things really start to go sideways
the message from his father is also a reference
to the ancestral plane saying that they'll search
every last place on this plane in the next
until they find him nebula sets up the whole
double triple cross storyline thinking now at this
point that she's double crossed them because they
haven't revealed the triple cross till later
in the episode claiming that she was using
t'challa to pay off her debt to the collector and
earlier in the episode when she said she brought
what the collector asked for the idea was is
that he wanted t'challa for his collection
the collector sours a little bit on t'challa then
orders ebony moth to dissect him and turn him into
a literal wall display then nebula reveals the
triple cross betraying the collector revealing
the heist within a heist saying that t'challa knew
what was going on from the start she told him how
everything was going to go down with the triple
cross i think just because they want this version
of nebula to seem like less of a dirt bag than
the movie version of nebula before she gets her
sort of hero's journey arc where she joins the
avengers by the time avengers end game picks up
she used the confusion to steal the embers of
genesis like they originally wanted and t'challa
uses his vibranium necklace to escape making
a black panther reference in the process using
the vibranium teeth of the necklace like panther
claws in his fist karina then double-crosses ebony
ma in the collector like she double-crossed
the collector during the guardians movie
the idea is that she's also inspired by t'challa
not liking putting people in cages and the idea
that t'challa was going to use the power stone
to save her homeworld the crylorians homeworld
this is also meant to be set up for the karma
payoff joke where the collector's trying to yell
at him about karma but then karma comes back
around in a negative way for him the collector
pulls out the severed arm of what he calls
a chatty cronin which like i said i think is
supposed to be a reference to korg because korg is
so chatty in the mcu so i guess r.i.p korg in this
universe then he whips out a whole bunch of easter
egg weapons so the dagger he says that is from the
ruler of the dark elves is a reference to malekith
from thor the dark world who i guess is dead in
this universe the thor of the dark world post
credit scene was also a collector scene of the
warriors 3 bringing him the 8th earth the reality
stone you see that he's also got captain america
shield and thor's hammer mjolnir so i guess
that means that they're both dead also in this
universe r.i.p then he whips out hella's crown
so i guess she's dead in this universe too r.i.p
to her as well he also references the necro sword
from the comics like i said which is a huge venom
null easter egg and gore the god butcher easter
egg who we're going to see in thor 11 thunder
gore is being played by christian bale in the
comics he wielded the necro sword which was the
primal symbiote created by null in the mcu they
changed that a little saying that hella created
these necro swords while the rest of the ravagers
are trying to escape thanos stays behind to stop
the black order making a reference to the mad
titan thanos saying that he's not crazy he's mad
he's still super powerful naturally so he can soak
a lot of this regular blaster fire without armor
and you get to see thanos versus cole obsidian
which is a nice callback reference to hulk
versus thanos during avengers infinity war
thanos catching his hammer blow here as an
easter egg for the avengers infinity war scene
of spider-man catching cole obsidian's hammer
trying to smash iron man then they start paying
off all these family references like i said
as the collector is taunting t'challa about his
wakandan family nebula hears thanos screaming
in pain when proxima midnight impales him with
their spear turning around to help him paying
off the family feud that they established earlier
in the episode they pay off the ravager never fly
a solo joke from earlier in the episode when yondu
comes to save t'challa from the collector he also
references t'challa as if he's his son the same
way he did for peter quill in guardians 2. nebula
uses some of the embers to save thanos throwing
them down cull obsidian's throat growing a huge
garden across nowhere then t'challa and yondu pull
a deep cut joke from thor ragnarok so when they
do their quote-unquote sticky fingers routine it's
them doing their version of get help and being the
glue means that he has to soak all the damage so
that he can get in close and quote-unquote sticky
fingers steal the collector's control device so
that t'challa can throw him into the holding cell
they give the device to karina who unlocks
everyone's cages the dark elf comes out this
crystalline person is pluvian just like martinex
from the og guardians 3000 team from guardians 2
and they pay off that collector's karma reference
from earlier in the episode when they all
kill him t'challa takes the wakandan spaceship
to escape and they show you what nowhere looks
like now as a garden i think this is also meant
to be a reference to thanos garden planet as well
then goes back to wakanda bringing the rest of the
ravagers with them to meet his biological family
they reveal thanos has taken a liking to
cosmo who's talking to okoye who makes another
genocide reference about his plan and it is deny
guerrero coming back to do the voice of okoye
this is korath trying to talk big game to
shuri when kragelin talks about jump points
scrambling your face that's a reference to that
scene from guardians of the galaxy 2 where they
do the huge jump point montage which was also
a big stanley cameo scene with the live-action
version of the watchers a lot of you wondered
about this now that jeffrey wright is uwatu
in the mcu and this series is canon to the mcu
i'm expecting jeffrey wright to come back as the
voice of live action uwatu eventually when they
get up to doing him in the movies you can all
theory craft about which movie live action uwatu
is going to show up during then at the end of the
episode as the watcher narrates about the dueling
family reunions they transition to missouri and
reveal that peter quill is working at the exact
same dairy queen from guardians of the galaxy to
where ego the living planet buried his spore
it's meant to be the exact same dairy queen
he's listening to 80s music on his walkman
another mixtape his mother would have made for him
and kurt russell comes back himself as ego of the
living planet from the movies it is implied that
he's got his same plan to take over the universe
from guardians 2. kind of a downer ending the
watchers saying that this might be bad spelling
the end of this world this universe really that
80 song that he's listening to on the walkman is
space age love song by flock of seagulls they're
also using the lyrics of that song as a metaphor
for the plot here i saw your eyes and it touched
my mind he's seeing ego's glowing eyes and ego
will touch his mind awakening his celestial powers
but if you spotted any other easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments it was a solid
episode probably going to be one of the best ones
from the season chadwick boseman was fantastic may
he rest in peace like i said he's going to be in
three more episodes this season my full what if
episode 3 video will post next week just like
normal i'll post a what if episode 3 trailer
video sometime in the next couple of days too
there's a couple big bonus videos that i do have
planned next week's episode will be a big loki
episode everyone click here for my non-spoilery
shanxi movie review and click here for my full
what if episode 1 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe in wakanda forever!